[Musique]
chez haribo tout commence dans la
cuisine pour une fois ce sont les hommes
qui sont aux fourneaux
il prépare les sirop de sucre avec des
recettes appelé formules comme dans un
labo chaque formule correspond à un type
de bonbons il en existe 90 et dans ma
cuisine ça ne plaisante pas il s'agit de
ne pas rater la cuisson pour fabriquer
les petits nounours que tout le monde
aime même eu apparemment on moule
d'abord leur empreinte dans de l'amidon
de maïs on poule ensuite le sirop auquel
on a ajouté plein de bons arômes et de
bon goût laurent la machine travail de 4
heures du matin à huit heures du soir et
le change de production chaque jour hier
les basques est aujourd'hui lé nounours
demain et dinosaures quand les plaques
de petits nounours ont coulé on les
stocke et on les laisse sécher pendant
48 heures à 55 degrés qu'est ce qu'il y
ait au goûter celui-là automatique au
mal c'est un peu un réflexe au goûter le
bonbon pouvant silva décida de la santé
oms il an'a pas systématiquement je vous
tous les produits de la société
chose qui va vous paraître bizarre mais
je consomme environ 250 à 300 g de monde
par jour depuis 1975
donc tout va bien
[Musique]
chez haribo à uzès ont produit cinq
types de bombes au des dragées fier
comme ici les dragibus les gélifiée
comme lé nounours les réglisses les
montées surtout les guimauves et là on a
senti comme une petite réticence il ya
quelques domaines qui sont un petit peu
réservé où nous avons une avance
technologique uniquement à la conserver
allez moi je vais vous le dire le
secteur secret c'est celui du gros
bonbon tendre mais comme on n'a pas le
droit d'en parler on vous laisse
savourer
oui
le chamallow a de beaux jours devant lui
car la tendance actuelle est au bon
moment en plus notre consommation de
sucre riz ne cesse d'augmenter
conclusion haribo embauche chaque année
de nouveaux salariés et salariés heureux
donc ses dirigeants quoi de faire
quelque chose on sait que ça va aboutir
dans les bouchons
petit d'enfants a sorti de l'école ou
qui me les grandes personnes
[Musique]